-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
This is exciting.
As of today,
all Americans 16 and older
are now eligible
for the COVID vaccine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And yet the biggest thing
trending online today was this.
-McDonald's partnering with
popular Korean pop band BTS.
The celebrity meal
goes on sale next month.
The meal features
10-piece chicken nuggets,
medium fries, and a Coke.
The fast food chain also
debuting two new dipping sauces.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Just so there's no confusion,
you get your BTS order
at McDonald's, and you get your
IBS order at White Castle.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-This is odd, but my nickname
at my local McDonald's is BTS
'cause whenever I order, they
think it's for seven people.
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, give me a number three,
and, uh -- you guys
still making pancakes?"
[ Laughter ]
I might throw
a couple of those in there."
-"What do you want?
What did you want?"
-Doing different voices.
[ Laughter ]
-"I'll have three small..."
-[ Russia accent ] "I would
like to get a Big Mac."
It's like, "Oh."
-"He wants a Big Mac, too."
-That's my Russian buddy.
-"And some fries!"
-Of course, adding the BTS name
to McDonald's
will drum up a lot of business,
but if BTS really wants
to impress me,
they'll put their name on
the Johnson & Johnson vaccine.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, guys,
now that the vaccine
is open to all Americans
16 and older,
the Biden administration
is trying to get the word out.
Watch this.
-The White House is launching
a media blitz today
to promote the vaccine.
-You're gonna be seeing
Dr. Fauci on unlikely forums
such as Snapchat,
and the administration is also
gonna be using
Facebook and Twitter
to send push notifications
to Americans to let them know
that it's their turn
to get vaccinated.
-So let me get this straight.
Your idea to get kids vaccinated
is putting an 80-year-old
scientist on TikTok?
[ Laughter ]
Good luck.
You know Biden's old
when he's like,
"We need someone young and hip
for the Snapchat videos.
How about that kid, Dr. Fauci?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I read that a lot
of singles have been meeting
while waiting in line
to get their vaccines.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
That's really sweet until that
moment when the masks come off.
Like...
[ Laughter ]
"We're good.
We're good."
You know someone didn't like you
when they skipped
their second dose just to avoid
seeing you again.
[ Laughter ]
Today, one guy in Rite Aid
was like, "Care to continue this
over by
the blood pressure machine?"
[ Laughter ]
All I know is,
we're probably days away
from the new Hallmark movie,
"Moderna Love."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is exciting.
Earlier this morning,
NASA made history on Mars.
Check it out.
-NASA is celebrating yet another
historic accomplishment
on the red planet,
successfully flying
a mini helicopter on Mars.
It's the first-ever powered
flight on another planet.
-That's right.
A little helicopter
detached from a rover, and now
they're both exploring Mars.
Or as Pixar put it, "Sold!"
[ Laughter ]
The flight lasted a total
of 30 seconds.
The men on the team said
it was a complete success
while the women agreed so they
wouldn't hurt anyone's feelings.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I saw that --
-Wow.
-I saw that Tinder user--
I saw that Tinder users
can get free lessons
on the language app Duolingo
so they can meet other
international singles.
It's amazing. The program
teaches you how to say "You up?"
in 40 different languages.
Unbelievable.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
big sports news from overseas.
Some of the world's
best soccer clubs
made a pretty
controversial decision.
Listen to this.
-12 of Europe's top clubs
have announced plans
to form a Super League.
Some of the wealthiest and most
successful teams from England,
Spain, and Italy say they plan
to form an exclusive new league
where they will compete
only amongst themselves.
-Right now, America's
thinking, "Whatever,"
while Europe's like --
[ English accent ]
Forget the virus.
This is the biggest threat
facing the world.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, this is a big deal
for Europeans
and your annoying friend
who wears a soccer jersey
to Saturday brunch.
[ Laughter ]
But this is strange.
To help promote
the new soccer league,
they're sending Dr. Fauci
out onto Snapchat.
-Really?
-Yeah, exactly.
-Wow!
-Some political news.
A new poll shows
Matthew McConaughey
is leading Governor Greg Abbott
by 12 points
in a hypothetical match-up
for governor of Texas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You like it.
When asked if he's actually
gonna run for office,
McConaughey said,
"I might, I might, I might."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
McConaughey is leading
the polls.
Between that and 4/20,
this is the best week
of his life, maybe.
[ Laughter ]
This all makes sense
'cause people in Texas
will always support
the party of Lincoln.
Correct?
-Nice, nice. Nice.
-Thank you, Higgins.
Historian.
-Yep.
-So you appreciate that humor.
-I appreciate --
I appreciate that.
Also, he did
"The Lincoln Lawyer," too,
so you got two Lincolns.
-That's right.
I heard he's reprising his role.
-Is he really?
-Mm-hmm.
-As what?
-The same lawyer.
[ Laughter ]
-Nicer car.
-Yeah.
Some entertainment news.
It was just announced
that a second "Downton Abbey"
movie is hitting theaters
later this year.
They've actually come up
with a great name
for the
"Downton Abbey" sequel --
"Prude Bridgerton."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is creepy.
Retailers are selling
a realistic muscular body suit
for people who want
to look fit this summer
without having to hit the gym.
Look at that thing.
Isn't that bizarre?
[ Laughter ]
Imagine you're about
to take things further,
and your guy's like, "Hold on.
I just got to take off
my rubber skin suit first."
[ Laughter ]
The suit costs more than $100,
and they're harder to get out of
than a Planet Fitness
membership.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, over the weekend,
TSA agents in Houston
found crystal meth
in a traveler's burrito.
I hate when that happens.
You get a burrito
with beans, cheese,
and crystal meth
when you actually ordered
a burrito with beans, cheese,
and crack.
[ Laughter ]
Seems like Johnson & Johnson
just can't catch a break.
Listen to this.
Back in March,
there was a contamination issue
at one of their vaccine plants,
and the FDA
is halting production while
it investigates.
Wait. They're halting
production now?
You know your company is in
trouble when millions of doses
are contaminated,
and it's not nearly
the worst part of your week.
Don't worry. Instead of fixing
the contamination problem,
they're just going to
rebrand their vaccine as...
Right now, the company
is in so much trouble,
Johnson is currently
not talking to Johnson.
It's that bad.
Well, guys, some big tech news.
Today was Apple's
"Spring Loaded" event,
the company's first
major product announcement
of the year.
It was a great event.
Nothing is more fun than seeing
all the new Apple products
that will be at the bottom
of a random drawer in a year.
Yeah, the big announcements were
a new purple iPhone
and a new iPad Pro that can
store up to 60,000 photos.
-Ooh!
-Wow.
If you need
more space than that,
either you're a photographer
or your kid got ahold
of your iPad for 10 minutes.
Yep, they unveiled the
purple iPhone
or, as people celebrating 4/20
put it, "Purple?"
That's right.
Today is 4/20.
I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sir, you clapped a little
too fast and too loud.
I read that 40%
of people who smoke
think 4/20 should be
a national holiday,
while the rest
skipped work today
because they thought
it was a national holiday.
Right now, there's so much
smoke in New York City,
every apartment looks like
it elected a new Pope.
Even Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
acknowledged
the day's significance
from the Senate floor.
Watch this.
-Today is what you might call
a very unofficial
American holiday -- 4/20.
[ Laughter ]
-This clip feels
exactly like the moment
everyone's parents
joined Facebook.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
I bet senators
take a hit every now and then.
I mean, how else do you explain
the clip of that senator
removing glasses
that weren't there?
-I'd like to begin
with R-1 religious worker visas.
[ Laughter ]
-And then he put them
back on again
after he made his point.
Can we just see it again, Alex?
-I'd like to begin with --
-Yeah, oops.
-R-1 religious.
-Oh! Some entertainment news.
I saw that Vin Diesel is going
to star in a live action movie
based on the old toy
Rock 'Em Sock 'Em Robots.
Say what you want,
but it's nice to finally see
a human taking over
a robot's job.
And, finally,
a diner in New Jersey
had a pretty interesting
problem. Watch this.
-A Canadian goose is
wreaking havoc in New Jersey.
The bird has been attacking
customers entering this diner
while it's protecting
its family.
At one point, the male goose
knocked down a man
and pecked his face,
leaving him with bruises.
-First of all, couldn't
the cameraman warn the people
before they almost
had their eyes pecked out?
Yeah, a crazed goose attacking
people outside a diner.
The goose was like, "Attacking?
I'm trying to keep these idiots
from eating indoors."
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Tomorrow, President Biden
and 40 other world leaders
are kicking off
a big virtual climate summit.
Yep, they're meeting virtually
because of the pandemic.
Otherwise, they would have flown
40 different private jets
to a meeting about the climate.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the guest list includes
Vladimir Putin, Bill Gates,
Pope Francis,
and one very stressed out
I.T. guy.
[ Laughter ]
"Your Holiness,
can you try closing the browser
and signing back in?"
[ Laughter ]
It's too bad the summit
isn't in person.
If people were sitting
alphabetically,
I'd love to hear the small talk
between the Pope and Putin.
It's like,
"Do you watch 'Scheisse Creek'?
[ Laughter ]
Dan Levy is the best, I mean.
Did you see episode
where Moira is --
Oh, they're talking to us."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Vladimir Putin agreed to attend.
It'll be weird
when someone says,
"Very funny torture rack
background, Vlad,"
and he's like,
"Right, joke, of course. Yes."
[ Laughter ]
All I know is that it'll be
awkward when they start the Zoom
and Putin and Biden
are the first ones on.
[ Laughter ]
"Stop video. Stop.
Hi, Joe. How's it going, man?"
[ Laughter ]
During the summit,
Biden is expected to announce
that the U.S. will cut
greenhouse gas emissions
at least in half by 2030.
That's good. Yeah. Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, Biden plans to cut
emissions by 2030,
at which point, it will be
President Dwayne Johnson's
problem.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this is big. Remember that
European soccer Super League
that was just announced
two days ago?
-Yeah.
-Well, listen to this.
-The proposed European
Super League may be over
before any teams
could even take the field.
The league announced it was
suspending current plans
after the founding clubs
backed out of the venture,
just two days
after the initial announcement.
-Wow. Only two days.
[ Laughter ]
I've seen guacamole
last longer than that.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, the league crumbled
faster than a Nature Valley bar.
-Oy, oh, hey!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yep, the Super League
has been knocked out
and, unlike most
soccer injuries,
this one's real.
[ Laughter ]
Now, those 12 teams are
showing up at their old leagues,
trying to act like nothing
happened. It's like --
[ English accent ]
Hey, what's up?
Does anyone here watch
"Shite's Creek"?
[ Laughter ]
Dan Levy's fantastic.
He's brilliant. Yeah.
You see the episode
where Moira is --
Oh, sorry.
They're talking.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news --
Netflix stock took a big dive
this week after they reported
a dramatic slowdown
in subscriber growth.
-Ooh!
-It's a tough time for Netflix.
Right now, executives are
fighting like two people
looking for something
to watch on Netflix.
[ Laughter ]
Things are so bad,
the CEO of Netflix was like,
"We either need a new
'Bridgerton' or a new pandemic."
[ Laughter ]
But Netflix isn't letting
the news discourage them.
They also announced that they're
spending more than $17 billion
on content this year.
Yeah, they're spending
$17 billion for shows
that we're just going to listen
to while we're on Instagram.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news --
I saw that Lululemon is testing
a resale program where shoppers
sell and buy gently used items.
-Ooh. Ooh.
-Lululemon yoga pants.
[ Laughter ]
Let me put this in perspective.
Wearing a pair of lightly used
Lululemon pants is basically
like picking up a pack
of lightly used Charmin.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
I don't even know how you'd sell
used Lululemons.
Anybody who wears them has
to cut them off with scissors.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
Maybe this'll work.
I mean, how many times have you
seen someone walking out
of a hot yoga class and thought,
"I want those shorts,
that exact pair"?
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, you're not going to
believe this,
but the pandemic
has had an effect
on the sales of Girl Scout
cookies. Listen to this.
-The lack of in-person sales
this year has left tons
of Thin Mints, Samoas,
and other flavors unsold.
-Troop leaders in Atlanta say
they have 700,000 boxes
just sitting in a warehouse.
-Wow.
I can't wait for my neighbor's
kid to be like,
"Oh, hi, Mr. Fallon,
so I can put you down
for 15,000 Do-Si-Dos?"
[ Laughter ]
All I have to say is
you know America's broken
when there's a surplus
of delicious cookies
and life-saving vaccines.
[ Laughter ]
What are we doing?
And get this -- in June,
New York City is getting
a 3-story, 21,000-square-foot
Harry Potter store.
-Ooh.
[ Audience oohs ]
-It's exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'd say there's
nothing hotter right now
than Harry Potter merchandise
and indoor shopping,
would you agree?
[ Laughter ]
It'll be the first time
a New Yorker can whip out
their wand on the subway
without getting pepper-sprayed.
[ Laughter ]
What, what, what?!
-Hey, hey!
Hey! Put away your Harry Potter.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm glad it's in New York City.
I mean,
what's better than hearing,
[ Brooklyn accent ]
"Welcome to the wizarding world
of Harry Potter"?
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Yeah, the store is based on
the previously
unreleased book...
[ Laughter ]
"Honey, let's stop in here.
Do we need a wand?
Oh, you answered
pretty quick there."
[ Laughter ]
Well, there have been a lot
of incredible strides made
in science over the past year,
but here's an invention
you probably weren't expecting.
Watch this.
-Engineers at Purdue University
have created
the whitest paint ever.
They say the paint is so white
that coating a building with it
could cool them off enough
to reduce the need
for air conditioning.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Yeah, the "scientists" work
at the distinguished
University of Benjamin Moore.
[ Laughter ]
Can we see
that paint color again?
Yeah, looks like a photo
from the Pillsbury Doughboy's
colonoscopy.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Today is Earth Day.
Happy Earth Day!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone's in the spirit.
This morning at 7-Eleven,
I saw a rat drinking a Big Gulp
with a metal straw.
-Aww.
-Yes -- So, yes.
A lot of stores
celebrated Earth Day.
H&M added a section
for sustainable items.
Lowe's offered a free
Garden-to-Go kit,
and Subway recycled
last week's tuna.
-Oh.
-So, yeah, I thought that was --
I'm kidding around,
but protecting the Earth
is serious. I mean --
[ Valley accent ]
Can you believe that, in 1999,
we had nearly 50
Rainforest Cafes,
and now we're down to almost 20?
[ Laughter ]
Think about it.
That's right.
Today was all about the planet,
and at the White House,
President Biden
hosted 40 world leaders
for a virtual
climate change summit.
The tone of the summit
was that we're all responsible.
But you know Costa Rica was
looking at the U.S. and China
like, "Yeah.
This is all our fault, right?
Yeah, we're --
We're all to blame. Yeah.
Huh. Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
Now, of course,
with any virtual event,
you're going to have some
technical glitches, right?
But I didn't think
it'd be quite this bad.
Take a look at what happened.
-[ Echoing ] Good morning
to all our colleagues --
all our colleagues
around the world,
the world leaders taking part
in the summit, I thank you.
-It's now my honor to call on
His Excellency, the secretary
general of the United Nations,
António Guterres.
[ No audio ]
[ Laughter ]
I now call upon
the Prime Minister
of the Republic of India,
His Excellency Narendra Modi.
-President Biden...
[ Phone dialing ]
...colleagues,
my fellow citizens.
[ Phone dialing ]
-The floor is now to
the president
of the Russian Federation,
Mr. Vladimir Putin.
Mr. President.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
[ Applause ]
Looking.
Somehow, we just flew
a helicopter on Mars,
but we still can't get
a Zoom meeting to work.
Next time, every leader
will be required
to have at least
one grandchild present.
[ Laughter ]
It's funny that we were
watching Putin
and he didn't know
he was on-camera,
'cause, usually,
it's the other way around.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Even --
-That was a good one.
-Preach?
-That was good.
-At one point, Britain's prime
minister, Boris Johnson, spoke
and he used a pretty interesting
phrase to get his point across.
Listen to this.
-This is not all
about some expensive,
politically correct green act
of -- of -- of bunny-hugging,
or however you want to put it.
There's nothing wrong
with bunny-hugging,
but you -- you know
what I'm driving at.
-No.
We have no idea
what you're driving at.
[ Laughter ]
At first, people were like, "Oh,
is bunny-hugging a British
version of tree-hugging?"
British people were like,
"No, he's just weird.
I've never heard that term."
That's right, leaders
from all over the world
met to discuss
climate change over Zoom,
and some even released joint
statements with President Biden.
Check these out.
After French President
Emanuel Macron said...
...Biden jumped in and said...
[ Applause ]
I --
-Wow.
-I don't really see
how that's relevant,
but let's check out
another joint statement.
After German Chancellor
Angela Merkel said...
...Biden said...
-Wait, what?!
-What?!
Like, why do they keep
letting him talk?
-Really?
-Yeah.
Let's check out one more.
-Alright, let's see it.
-After British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson said...
...Biden said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-Ralph and Ralph?
I don't know.
-They sound like
"joint" statements.
-I don't know, man.
More news from Washington.
After the White House presented
its $2.3 trillion
infrastructure plan,
Republicans have responded
with their own version,
that's only worth $568 billion.
Yeah, Republicans want all these
repairs done on the cheap,
which is why they're calling
the bill Operation Flex Seal.
[ Laughter ]
Biden has so much
on his plate -- infrastructure,
construction, police reform,
military spending --
right now, his to-do list
looks like the Village People.
[ Laughter ]
This is pretty incredible.
I saw that Amazon is testing out
a new way to pay at Whole Foods.
Take a look at this.
-Paying for groceries
with a swipe of your hand.
That could be coming soon
to Whole Foods stores near you.
It allows shoppers
to pay for items
by placing their palm
over the scanning device.
-Here's how it works. You hover
your hand over the reader,
then the cashier tells you
to stay still,
then move it slightly,
then move it slightly again,
and then you get frustrated
and pay with your credit card.
-Wow. Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Whatever. I think it's fun.
I always wanted to buy plums
like I'm a Jedi.
-Beep!
[ Laughter ]
-That's pretty good, right?
-Beep. Yeah, that's
a pretty good Jedi.
-Like, it's
the move back that's --
-The move back
is what sells it. Yeah.
That's just a guy.
-Yeah.
-That's a Jedi.
-Thank you.
-Especially with the flourish.
-Are they making another
"Star Wars" film?
-I bet they -- Oh. You could --
-I added a little mustard
on that last one.
You want me to do it
one more time?
-Do it one more time.
-Mr. Lucas?
Okay.
Step to the left? Yeah. More?
-More?
-How far?
-Okay, perfect.
This is good?
-Do I have a car?
-Okay.
Thank you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
An Academy Award?
Oh, it's not --
My name's not on it.
-Oh, this isn't good.
McCormick said
that they've had a difficult
time keeping up with demand
for Old Bay Seasoning
during the pandemic.
Can't really imagine why,
which brings us to a new segment
we like to call
"Tariq's Teachable Moment."
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Thanks, Jimmy. I think
I can shine a light on this.
You see, when Black people cook,
we enjoy this thing
that you might have heard of.
It's called flavor.
[ Laughter ]
Flavor is what happens to a meal
when you add more to it
than just salt or pepper.
-I don't know.
That sounds spicy.
-It can be.
In Black homes, spice racks
are like guard dogs --
robust, loud, integral parts
of the family unit.
Meanwhile, your spice rack
is more like a lap dog --
small, decorative,
but ultimately useless.
So, when the pandemic hit
and restaurants closed,
Black people treated Old Bay
like it was toilet paper
and bought enough
to fill a bunker.
-Okay, well, how much seasoning
should I use?
-A great start would be
more than zero.
[ Laughter ]
Just do what I do.
Ignore the recipe
and sprinkle it on
a little longer
than you usually would.
Like this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
-Okay, this seems like a lot.
-It is.
That's the point, Jimmy.
And, look, if you don't
understand, yet, that's okay.
Just give it a minute
to marinate.
[ Ding! ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-Tariq Trotter, everybody.
Tariq Trotter.
I learned a lot.
Thank you, Tariq.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, finally,
a woman in North Carolina
was shopping at Target
when she found
a surprise on the shelf.
Watch this.
-Aah!
-This is not something
you typically find
on the shelves in Target --
a black rat snake
slithering through the cans
of Bush's Baked Beans.
-Ooh.
-Manager came on the PA system
and was like, "Oh, hell, no,
in Aisle 5. Oh, hell, no."
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Well, we've all gotten used
to wearing masks wherever we go,
but I just read that the CDC
is looking into whether
it's still necessary
to wear them outdoors.
-Oh?
-Ohh.
-That's all this country
needs right now --
Trevor,
the bartender from Señor Frog's,
to have been right all along.
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "I told you, bro!"
I guess this is good,
although I was kind of
looking forward
to another summer
with bikini lines on my face,
you know?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Honestly,
it would be nice to get back
to when a masked man
outside your house
was just a serial killer,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, it's a big weekend
for Hollywood.
The 93rd annual Oscars
are this Sunday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Of course, in quarantine, even
the Oscar statue gained weight.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's gonna be a very
unique year for the Oscars.
There's no host, no after party,
and no movies anyone saw.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep, this year's Oscars
are about celebrating
all the movies
we scrolled through and thought,
"20 bucks? Nope."
[ Laughter ]
But this is interesting --
the Academy announced
that masks are not required
while cameras are rolling,
but should be worn
during commercial breaks.
-Huh?
-That makes sense.
-Yeah.
-If we've learned anything
about the virus,
it only spreads
during commercials.
[ Laughter ]
And, speaking of movies, today,
"Mortal Kombat" was released
in theaters and on HBO Max.
I haven't seen
the new "Mortal Kombat," yet,
but I think I speak
for everyone when I say
I just hope
it lives up to the play.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, check this out -- Netflix
is reportedly nearing a deal
on an upcoming biopic
about the band KISS,
called "Shout It Out Loud."
Yeah, it's pretty exciting news.
-[ Chuckling ]
Yeah, Jimmy, so exciting.
[ Light laughter ]
-Higgins, I didn't realize
you were such a big KISS fan.
-What? No, no, no.
I just love biopics.
[ Light laughter ]
-I-I see.
Did you know in advance
that I'd be talking
about a KISS biopic today?
-No. Just took a chance.
I wear KISS makeup to work
about half the time.
-Alright.
You can't wear that
during the show.
-Ugh.
Fine.
You never support me, anyway.
-Oh, come on.
I -- Thanks, buddy.
I-I appreciate it.
-Oh, you know what?
It's me. I'm sorry...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Get this --
starting on May 1st,
topless clubs in Las Vegas
are officially allowed
to reopen.
[ Scattered cheers ]
Phew!
Just in time for Mother's Day,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
If you're excited
about topless clubs reopening,
I'm assuming
it was a long quarantine.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this --
Nathan's is offering
5-cent hot dogs at Coney Island
this summer
for the first time in 100 years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Applause ]
Customers were like,
"Uh, I'd actually feel better
if you charged more."
[ Laughter ]
5-cent hot dogs?
I'd rather get
5-cent LASIK eye surgery.
[ Laughter ]
What?
Eating a 5-cent hot dog
is as safe
as taking home a mattress
on the street that says, "Free."
[ Laughter ]
"Seems like a good deal.
-"Hey. Yeah."
-Let's take it
back to the house."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I saw that Martha Stewart
just announced
the release
of her 99th cookbook.
-Whoo!
-Oh.
-99. At this point,
the recipes are just...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Rude.
-It says, "Leave me alone,"
in the book.
-Wow.
Very rude for a cookbook.
-She would never.
Did you guys hear about this?
An explosion
at a gender-reveal party --
oh, my gosh --
in New Hampshire
was so powerful that it damaged
[Chuckling] nearby homes
and was felt in other states.
-What?
-What? Like what's up with these
gender-reveal parties?
Like --
-[ Laughs ]
After the explosion, everyone
was like, "It's a...
lawsuit!"
[ Laughter ]
What is going on
with these things?
-It's crazy.
-Yeah. They're supposed
to reveal the gender
of the baby,
not the IQ of the parent.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, this made me laugh --
a man in Taiwan
is making news for finding
an interesting way
to get some extra time
off from work.
Listen to this story.
-A man in Taiwan
found a creative way
to get an extended
vacation from work.
He initially got married
last April.
He was given
eight days off.
At the end of his leave,
he divorced his wife
and planned to remarry her
the next day.
And he did this whole process
not once, not twice,
but three times.
-[ Laughing ] Wow.
Wow! Yeah.
His boss knew something was up
when he got a letter
that said...
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
a woman here in New York City
came home to her apartment
and found an unexpected visitor.
Watch this.
♪♪
[ Audience groans ]
-What?!
-Wow. I didn't even know
New York City pigeons laid eggs.
[ Laughter ]
I thought they were just rats
that earned their wings.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry, though --
the pigeon's gone, and --
this is no relation at all --
I just want to remind everyone
about Nathan's 5-cent hot dogs
this summer on Coney Island.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy summer, everybody!